foreign
is in Orlando hi Roman how are you
hey Mr Dave how are you doing better
than I deserve how can I help
uh yes hi Ms Jade hey what's going on a
question uh oh not much my question is
um should I stop or reduce my
contributions to my 457 in order to pay
off my mortgage sooner rather than later
and by sooner I mean probably by
February of next year with your mortgage
your third child is due your mortgage
correct how come it says car on my
screen
uh because it was either the mortgage or
the car but my wife told me no the
mortgage not the car and I was like oh
okay your wife's wrong
oh probably a novel idea for her but
she's wrong
not to mention that yeah I noticed that
yeah if you're in baby step two if
you're in baby step two you would pause
in investing contributions but if you
would attack your car loan yes because
that would be part of baby step two
so that's how that works if you pay off
the car but what do you owe on your car
yeah
uh 24. and what's your household income
uh single income one about 120. okay
let's get it good and um what do you owe
on your house
uh 48 okay a thousand yeah we're gonna
pay off the car
I mean do you have any money in savings
uh we do actually we have a we have 35
000 in savings and twenty of that is a
uh pay off your car pay off your car
today
now
write a check tonight
stop your for and then you don't have to
stop your 457 by the way you build your
emergency fund so babies you're fairly
new to us Roman and we're picking on you
I'm sorry because you don't you don't
know you don't know all this stuff you
just walked into the Bears yes you did
you did I'm sorry so let's start let's
start let's start let's start again and
we'll start nice okay here's nice now
what we teach is a thing called the baby
steps and the first step is a thousand
dollars saved you've done that step two
is to become debt free other than your
home this is the fastest way to wealth
as proven by the largest study of
millionaires ever done okay
so this is not a game and it's not an
accident it's not something we made up
because we're on YouTube or some crap
okay this is stuff we've been doing for
30 years and we've LED more people out
of debt and into wealth than anybody
else this is the process we used baby
step two is pay off everything but your
house that would be your car and your
case and you have the money oddly enough
in your account to write a check today
and do that right
yes yes we do actually so now you're
debt free now then baby step three other
than your house baby step three is have
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses if you don't quite have that
left over after you pay off the car
let's round that up real quick maybe
step four is 15 of your income going
into retirement I would prefer a 401k or
Roth IRAs over a 457 a 457 is just
Deferred Comp
so I'd prefer to do that unless you're
getting a match there that wouldn't be
my first stop and then with any money I
can find the budget I'm Gonna Knock Out
this little bitty mortgage you got and
I'll be on your wife's team at that
point but it takes me a while to get to
your wife's team hey thanks for calling
in man